freunde es ist passiert ich bin in die
top ten
ich wollte eigentlich gerade gar nicht
agrio aufnehmen allerdings sieht doch
dass wir gott oder viert dann gerade ich
bin hier derzeit wieder sehr viel am
vorproduzieren und wenn dann videos mal
zehn minuten rennen dann denke ich mir
mal so joop kannst du schnell eine runde
addio einfach im browser spielen komme
ich bin doch sogar 33 tag alles klar
luca den ich mir ja auch kaum spielst du
schnell ne runde ko ist ja nicht so
schlimm
und jetzt bin ich einfach richtig
erfolgreich ich bin oder ist der erste
da ist der manta fucking erste ich bin
einfach mal ob ich bin grad sechster
aber ich bin fit nein wir wissen er so
schnell wie kann das sein die wissen ja
so schnell bitte teilt ich jetzt sich
auf bitte das kann doch nicht sein dass
obwohl man einst auch er geht weg zum
glück jedenfalls ich spiele das so hast
du die ganze diese kleine scheiße
gegessen so wie ich das halt immer mache
und irgendwann kam dann halt immer mehr
andere leute und die sind alle nicht
eingefahren irgendwie obwohl ich nicht
irgendwie geht schmiedet haft so hey
helft mir oder irgendwie so sondern
heißt halt einfach ganz normal luca und
bin einfach und so ein paar leute rein
gefahren habe man mehr gefressen und
irgendwann war ich dann auf einmal
dritter und das ist mir gar nicht so
krass aufgefallen weil ich nach wie vor
bestimmt sind alle so groß und ich bilde
mir das noch ein aber dann war ich
tatsächlich recht gut und jetzt versuche
ich das ganze zu halten der polo ist
hinter mir und das macht mir ein
bisschen zu schaffen gerade weil der
nahezu genauso groß ist beziehungsweise
der ist größer als ich und er könnte
mich halt locker auffressen deswegen
mache ich mir da so ein bisschen angst
dass ich jetzt dass mein top ten
aufenthalt von nicht so lange dauer ist
sie sind alle gleich groß da mache ich
eigentlich keine sorgen ok freunde wir
sind es elf meine beiden verschmelzen
sich sogar gerade dass ich eventuell
gleich diesen dodo hier direkt essen
kann
kom kom kom kom kom luca frisst dich
rein frisst ihn nicht rein
das kann auch jetzt noch nicht so schwer
sein das ist wirklich die erste runde
nicht richtig gut bin ich fühle mich
richtig stark in diesem spiel auf einmal
jetzt können wir eventuell sogar diesen
salons hier horn ein der ist viel zu
riesig wenn der mich jetzt auf riss dann
heule ich aber wie sonst was der macht
jetzt bitte sendet jetzt bitte keine
mich ich habe nur dieses eine mal dass
ich in den top ten im bund wir fressen
haben wir fressen stalin sondern
staatlichen gefressen
ich weiß nicht was dazu sagen soll ich
wollte heute eigentlich wirklich gar
kein addio hochladen
allerdings habe ich dann auch spaß
gespielt ich bin einfach in die top ten
gekommen ich kann es 1000 mal wieder
hoffe ich dass ich ein bisschen licht
weil ich fühle mich gerade voll gut weil
ich endlich mal was reißen in dem spiel
ich bin auf platz sechs gerade das ist
zwar nicht so gut wie ich gerade war da
war ich kurzzeitig platz drei kommen
jetzt schlängelt sich hier durch luca
der andere hat auch keine andere
möglichkeit ihre okay da kann dann links
um aber der mond mit dem mond haben wir
eher eine rechnung auf das krasseste
wäre wenn jetzt die niederlande kommt
oder so das ziel für heute wird gesetz
auf platz eins wenn ich hier schon auf
dem sechsten platz bin da kann man
natürlich auch noch höheren zielen
streben und natürlich den platz eins
anstreben kommen schon kommen schon
kommen schon ja ja ja ja ja ja ich habe
ein teil vom bund bekommen jetzt in die
neue ja ich hab den morgen meine rache
geht ich bin ja so stolz auf mich auf
ein kürzlich klar dass das hat mich dann
wieder ab mein zimmer ist zur
sonnenseite und da mache ich einmal die
fenster auf dann bin ich wieder weiß
wieso einen geist oder so jetzt läuft
wieder da und ist der ie oder irgendwie
so heißt der und grollt sich da die
ganze zeit ein zu recht mit seiner
hellblauen farbe ich weiß nicht ob ich
es hinkriege den da irgendwie gefangen
zu halten er ist jetzt in der ecke
eingesperrt das heißt sein einziger der
einzige ausweg wäre jetzt nicht zu
teilen oh mein gott ist das wenn ich den
kriege bin ich locker auf platz drei
wieder kommen schon kommen schon kommt
schon luca holte ihn hole ihn holen so
und jetzt ihnen noch schnell holen so
jetzt bin ich zwar vier geteilt aber ich
bin auf platz 3 ich bin auf platz drei
freunde wir sind nun allerdings auch
sehr leicht angreifbar wir haben vorne
den kleinen luca der natürlich schneller
ist als der dicke luca ganz hinten ich
weiß nicht zuletzt place aufnehmen ist
eigentlich extrem komisch mal führt
quasi die ganze einfach selbstgespräche
rausch it da oben kommt österreich ich
muss mich nur irgendwie wieder zusammen
passen irgendwie aber ich bin mir noch
nicht ganz genau sicher wir wurden so
ein paar tipps in die kommentare
geschrieben und am letzten teil dass
sich die irgendwie zusammen ziehen soll
und dann vereinen die sich wurde war
aber irgendwie habe ich davon noch
nichts irgendwie aus werden können dafür
eigentlich gerade zwei da oben den
musste ich muss nochmal irgendwen von
denen hier nochmal fressen können aber
bisher habe ich auf jeden fall schon
mehr gefressen als in den ganzen letzten
teil zusammen wie eventuell kriege ich
top ten wenn jetzt alle sich irgendwie
zusammen ziehen dann müsste ich
allerdings wieder in die andere richtung
gehen und das traue ich mich gerade
nicht anwesend aufgebaut wie sonne
rauten formation
ja oh ja ich will auf platz zwei ich bin
auf platz zwei ich glaub man das paket
platz zwei jetzt muss nur noch der platz
eins er ich bin der zweitgrößte in der
kompletten web wie krank ist das denn
bitte das ist dann wahrscheinlich der
erste oder österreich hilft mir einmal
in deinem leben kommen nicht wahr oder
du spielst du bist platz drei wenn ich
dich gefressen kriege dann bin ich ja so
fällig dann bin ich ja so fertig mit der
welt dann wäre ich der allergrößte in
der verdanken
ich weiß der ein oder andere spieler
sagt jetzt höhe und bin ich hier glauben
vom schlafen den fünf mal
aber mir das ist für mich etwas komplett
neues das in neue welten dass ich gut
bin in einem spiel das ist unfassbar
sorry dass ich so ein bisschen emotional
gerade bin aber ich war noch nie in den
top ten
und jetzt bin ich mal da drin und jetzt
bin ich sogar auf platz zwei platz nada
fucking 2 komme ich teil mich immer
wieder damit ich ein bisschen schneller
unterwegs bin und hier vielleicht ein
paar mehr von diesen teilen ihr fressen
kann
mein ziel ist es jetzt eigentlich ein
paar kleine zu fressen dass ich
irgendwann größer bin als casey das
wahrscheinlich in seinem casey fake oder
irgendwie so wo gott und da oben kommt
ksc da oben kommt k s ich hoffe notation
jetzt nicht das map ende irgendwo ist
denn da oben kommt case er darf sich
nicht bitten aber er weiß wahrscheinlich
dass wenn er sich später dass er quasi
genauso groß ist wie ich das für uns
kein großer abstand ist er hat sich
gefreut hat sich gebildet der sich
gebildet
ok jetzt muss ich nur irgendwie davon
komme ich muss irgendwie davon kommen
hier wird er nicht rumkommen hier wieder
nicht rumkommen genau weil er dafür zu
riesig ist genau der war das wieder eine
knappe aktion gerade ich hoffe ich dass
ausschnitt das war die gehen oft essay
luca aber vereine die ich vereine dich
vereine dich kom kom kom kom kom kommt
nur noch ihr beiden hier ineinander dann
gehen wir direkt auf casey von werner
keller gefressen haben dann sind wir auf
platz 1 luca wir sind auf platz 2 gerade
aber vielleicht kommen dann noch platz
eins jetzt sind wir auf luke jetzt
müssen wir irgendwie den casey kriegen
wir müssen ihm irgendwie fressen wir
müssen nur casey verfolgen und dann
töten und dann sind wir auf platz eins
mein gott bin ich gerade emotional mit
dabei er oder ich er oder ich oder ich
oh mein gott er dinge kriegt auch
scheiße jetzt ist das bleibt natürlich
umgekehrt waren spannendes battle gerade
ich will das video ein
gar nicht so gehalten aber wir kommen
irgendwie nicht vorankommen ich fühlte
mich jetzt hier einfach noch mal und
dann versuchen wir auch comics bitte
mich sogar nochmal wir fahren jetzt
einfach mal zu viert um so ein bisschen
jolo action und essen wir noch ein paar
andere riss priolo sind wir wenig größer
kann ich interessen nein kann ich nicht
scheiße aber mein kleiner lukas
definitiv kleiner als er kommt freunde
wir müssen pro jahr irgendwie kriegen
das ist unsere einzige hoffnung auf
platz 9 was macht der ich dafür wären
freunde kommen wir müssen pro jahr
fressen das ist unsere einzige hoffen
wir sind sogar nur noch platz 23 jetzt
jetzt jetzt wohl durch priolo holt euch
priolo ja ja um ein ganz freunde wird
erster hier sind erst da das erste mal
in meinem leben ich muss mich jetzt
definitiv ruhige halten weil nebenan ich
höre bei meinen nachbarn halt immer wenn
die bauern oder irgendwas anderes oder
kochen oder irgendwie sowas und ich
streiche rum wie so ein spalter hier
sind erst einige dieser tag mussten die
geschichtsbücher eingehen freunde
schreibt alle in die kommentare
lukas ja gibt mir noch mehr
diese ukulele tut mir so leid meiner
gegenwart das ist echt unfassbar
freunde wir sind platz eins
[Musik]
jetzt schauen wir mal noch fressen
können gar ach du heilige scheiße casey
nein nein case ey du kriegst mich nicht
schon ein hohn ein case lass mich in
ruhe lasst mich in ruhe nein nein nein
das kann nicht sein das kann nicht wahr
sein ich bin nur noch zweiter nein ritt
durch luca nein nein käse hinein tut mir
das nicht antun dass ich an ich bin nur
auf platz wir haben unser platz eins
erreicht das heißt ich opfere mich an
casey
ich bin eh schon tot da freundlich
hoffen euch hat dieses video gefallen es
war sehr emotional für mich weil ich
endlich den platz ein szenario erreicht
das möchte die noch in agadir video